Da warten wir seit monaten auf das bild aus dem zentrum der galaxie aus einem weltumspannenden
netz an teleskopen wird es ja zurzeit aus unmengen von daten errechnet da erreicht uns jetzt eines mit
details die wir so noch nie gesehen haben jetzt könnt ihr endlich ein
altes rätsel gelöst werden worum es sich handelt jetzt den klicks und science fiction herzlich willkommen
In rund 25.000 lichtjahren entfernung liegt das zentrum unserer galaxie der milchstraße
sie ist ja so genannt weil die milliarden sterne aus denen sie besteht am nachthimmel eher wie eine
milchstraße aussehen denn wie einzelne sterne und die kann man auch nur auf dem land sehen wo es keine lichtverschmutzung
durch die städtische beleuchtung gibt und das zentrum unserer galaxie ist dann in dieser milchstraße so weit von uns entfernt
dass es hinter den stern neben und stoppt ansammlungen verborgen ist aber es kann
beobachtet werden wenn auch nicht leicht aber mit radioteleskopen sie
fotografieren strahlung die bis zu uns vor dringend gerade wurde das größte seiner art auf der südhalbkugel in der karoo wüste in
südafrika eingeweiht und schon liefert es ein spektakuläres bild aus dem herzen unserer galaxie ist bildet die strahlung rund um das zentrale
supermassereiche schwarze loch im zentrum sagittarius a stern ab mehr
cat heißt das teleskop und besteht aus 64
radio antenne schüssel mit einem durchmesser von jeweils 13 einhalb metern und so deutlich wie es jetzt das zentrum unserer milchstraße
abgebildet hat haben wir dieses noch nie gesehen es war auch das erste ziel dass das neue radioteleskop
anvisieren sollte fernando kamille vom seifigen
radioastronomie
observatorio dazu es ist einzigartig
optisch eindrucksvoll und voller unerklärt der phänomene aber auch notorisch schwer mit radioteleskopen
abzubilden es ist also selbst mit radioteleskopen
eines der schwersten motive doch die arbeit hat sich jetzt gelohnt gut darauf zu sehen sind die starken radio quellen rund um sarah stern
und aber auch zahlreiche dünne
filamente fäden die aus der region um das schwarze loch nach oben und unten heraus ragen sie wurden bereits in den 80er jahren
des letzten jahrhunderts entdeckt aber auch noch heute kann man nichts über sie sagen welcher natur sind sie woher kommen sie genau
zitat
das mir cap bild zeigt nun viele strukturen und merkmale die wir noch nie zuvor gesehen haben das sagt farhat josef cad von
der northwestern university in evanston
darunter sind beispielsweise
kompakte radio quellen die mit einigen dieser filamente verknüpft zu sein scheinen
diese daten könnten den schlüssel liefern um das drei jahrzehnte alte rätsel um die filamente zu lösen
ja wenn ihr keine videos zur lösung dieses rätsels und zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann hättet mich bei whatsapp dann umgeht er die
kaputte aber ob sie auf youtube und verpasst kann video denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir noch vor allen andern
vom neuesten video und zwar täglich
umquartiert einfach hier draufklicken und am besten auch meinen schwesterkanal klicks um social media abonnieren
da gibt es das neueste aus der social media welt dafür hier klicken aber nicht die
genau die glocke vergessen und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken foto von hubsen dem schwarzen doch bis dann
bleibt dran